what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
um today i have a morning coffee thought
um i know that i said i'd quit coffee
um but the problem is i never mean it
i never do look it i don't drink and i
know a bunch of you saw that one video
and you thought i was drunk
but no that's just my personality i
don't know what to tell you
um
no i don't drink i don't do drugs
my addiction is
sugar coffee
i'm sorry okay but anyways
so
today i want to talk about something
that
oh gosh my mom has been telling me for
years and i never listened but now
i see what she's talking about
and that's about image and the way you
dress and the way you portray yourself
um
so
last couple months like six months ago
you guys will remember i was online and
i was literally in sweats every day
doing
doing my content and everything
and
well i think on one level people relate
to you a little bit more when you like
dress down you know what i mean and like
people like it makes you seem more down
to earth and i mean i am pretty down to
earth
but
what i didn't realize is that people
take you a lot more seriously when you
start
taking your appearance seriously
and
that if you want a certain job you need
to dress for it and that that's like the
the connect my mom has always told me
this i just never listened i was always
that tomboy kid that was like whatever
mom you don't know what you're talking
about
and
i used they used to bother me because my
mom would always be the one that would
like
mention it if i gained weight or like
always be on me about dressing better
and like i'm and i was just like an
athlete kid so i'm like whatever mom
but the older i get the more i'm like
one glad that she fat shamed me because
um a lot of my friends whose parents
didn't fat that shame them are fat i say
this isn't sugar coffee looking i'm not
a perfect person
um when i'm out here i can like
squat 250 i can dead lift close to 300
like 300 i'm
i'm in really good shape and a lot of it
is because my mom always told me how
important it was to work out
and but on top of working out
dressing for the job you want is so
important when i wear because look at
this is my dress today it's my mother's
when i told my mom i was gonna start
dressing better she said i've been
waiting for this my whole life
she's like finally finally she gives me
all her old dresses
but it's like people look at you with a
different sense of credibility when you
show up for yourself because when you
show up for yourself and you care about
the way you look
it makes people respect you more and
just automatically assume
that you're more credible it's like when
you see a guy in a suit like a nice suit
there's just a level of respect that he
demands in a room and it doesn't mean
you have to spend a ton of money on it
or
you know it's not like you can't ever
dress down but
this is something that i wish i did
sooner because
it is important it's the message that
you're sending out to the world about
what you look like and who you are and a
lot of girls
don't understand that if they dress a
certain way
it'll get you attention but it's the
wrong kind of attention and this has
happened to me before too i'm really
tall so sometimes i like unintentionally
wear stuff that's just a little bit too
short and it's inappropriate it gives
you the wrong type of attention
um and i think there's just a balance
between
like obviously we don't want to look
like a grandma
and i know sometimes i do that and
um
but looking like professional and over
the age of
25
um i i just think
in general
in professional settings we really
shouldn't be wearing like jordans or
i was having this conversation with jess
converse because
we want to be taken seriously as a
content creator and as
you know a professional um
and
a lot of times guys especially men i see
this in men they they take pride in
looking like [ __ ]
and um i have i've seen this with my dad
too and don't get me wrong like
competence shows through all so you
could be wearing
a terrible outfit you could be looking a
mess and if you are competent like it'll
shine through this has happened to me so
many times like when i was wearing
sweats or whatever but
people could see that that i had a
higher level of competence or energy or
interest in what they were talking about
so it didn't matter and so i'm not
saying dress is everything but
when you walk into a room you only have
one chance to make a first impression
and why make it harder than it needs to
be
why make it harder than it needs to be
like instead of having to overcome your
looks they can assist you
and i wish and you can almost like
reinvent yourself because
image
if a guy
even if a guy's making 45k average guy a
year if he starts wearing a suit
everywhere people just take him more
seriously i can't i can't explain why
and it's the same thing with women and
like doing your hair doing your makeup
um putting on a nice dress like
your
your beauty is currency and it's not
just for women it's for men too
people take men more seriously when
they're in a suit people take men more
seriously when they're tall people take
i know i know you guys can't help that
but people take men more seriously when
they're in shape and this isn't fun like
this isn't a fun reality it should all
be based on competence but it's not
so
you know it's almost like why don't we
let the system work with us
so that is my morning coffee thought and
that is why the last couple of months
you've seen me
up my wardrobe and i will say it also
you just stand taller like when you have
on a nice outfit you you literally just
stand taller and you feel more confident
like walking around and i don't know how
to explain it but
when you are the best dressed person in
the room like you just you just your
shoulders are back you feel a lot better
you act a lot more confident so if you
want a job dress for the job you want
um
and you would be surprised how much
dressing up impacts your behavior so i'm
i'm learning with you guys i learned
this stuff too so
um that's my morning coffee thought
let me know any comments
any tips in the comments to quit coffee
because i don't think i'll ever do it
but you never know bye guys